en este vídeo vamos a revisar otro
ejemplo de una economía muy simple en la
cual sólo hay una agricultora y un
constructor en una isla repasaremos lo
que ya hemos aprendido acerca del
multiplicador y la propensión marginal
al consumo pero vamos a hacerlo de una
manera un poco más abstracta solo como
un breve repaso la propensión marginal
al consumo es un número que se encuentra
entre 0 y 1 en otras palabras se
obtienen un dólar cuánto de ese dólar
gastarán si su propensión marginal al
consumo es 0.25 quiere decir que
gastarán 25 centavos de ese dólar si
obtienen 1000 dólares y su propensión
marginal al consumo es 0.6 quiere decir
que gastarán 6 décimos o sea 600 dólares
vamos a mantener esta idea en una línea
abstracta empecemos con la agricultora
ella gasta x dólares en productos o
servicios del constructor entonces x
dólares pasan a manos del constructor y
qué va a hacer él ya hablamos de esto en
el vídeo anterior
el constructor va a decir tengo x
dólares y quiero gastar una parte
supondremos que todos los habitantes
de esta isla tienen la misma propensión
marginal al consumo y que solo hay un
lugar donde gastar es una economía muy
sencilla entonces cuánto va a gastar el
constructor bueno pues va a gastar x por
la propensión marginal al consumo si les
parece demasiado abstracto pausa en para
reflexionarlo supongamos que x son mil
dólares y la propensión marginal al
consumo es de 25 centésimas o 0.25
el constructor va a gastar 1000 por 0.25
o sea 250 dólares de pronto la
agricultora tiene todo este dinero que
va a ser bueno pues va a gastar porque
tiene una propensión al consumo la
propensión marginal al consumo entonces
va a gastar x por la propensión marginal
al consumo que es la cantidad que
recibió del constructor y cuánto de eso
va a gastar bueno pues otra vez esto por
la propensión marginal al consumo
entonces sería la propensión marginal al
consumo elevada al cuadrado y esto puede
seguir así una y otra vez el constructor
va a recibir esta cantidad otra vez va a
gastar esto por la propensión marginal
al consumo
y podemos seguir así indefinidamente
pero si queremos determinar cuánto
aumentó el gasto en esta economía como
consecuencia de ese gasto inicial de x
dólares tendremos que sumar todo
entonces sería x + x por la propensión
marginal al consumo + x por la
propensión marginal al consumo elevada
al cuadrado más etcétera si queremos
podemos factorizar una x entonces x por
1 más la propensión marginal al consumo
más la propensión marginal al consumo
elevada al cuadrado más etcétera y tal
vez reconozcan de sus clases de álgebra
o de pre cálculo que ésta es una serie
geométrica infinita
hemos hablado de ellas en otros vídeos
si los han visto sabrán que pueden sumar
todo esto es una de las cosas más
sensacionales de las matemáticas pueden
sumar todo esto como expresión
equivalente a 1 sobre 1 - la propensión
marginal al consumo entonces tenemos
este gasto inicial de x pero la cantidad
total de gasto en la economía
simplificada es x veces esta expresión y
por eso a esta expresión se le conoce
como multiplicador si la agricultora
gasta inicialmente un dólar en el
constructor entonces será un dólar por
esta expresión en términos de cuánto
aumentó el gasto en esta economía
simplificada entonces este es el
multiplicador vamos a escribirlo ahora
hagamos algo interesante y nuevo que
nunca hemos hecho supongamos que por
arte de magia aparece un gobierno en
esta isla y ese gobierno decide cobrarle
impuestos a la agricultora por la razón
que se les ocurra vamos a llamar del
tate a esa cantidad que el gobierno le
quita a la agricultora y esto es
positivo quiere decir que el gobierno
está obteniendo dinero y lo recibe de la
agricultora entonces qué va a hacer ella
desde su punto de vista ahora tiene del
tate menos dólares y eso va a afectar su
consumo va a disminuirlo pero en qué
cantidad bueno pues en la cantidad que
ella tiene que darle al gobierno por
tantas veces sea su propensión marginal
al consumo esto tiene lógica porque en
la situación donde le damos a la
agricultora un dólar si la propensión
marginal al consumo es 0.5 y le damos a
ella un dólar pagas
50 centavos pero si le quitamos los
impuestos va a gastar menos de los 50
centavos la cantidad total que quitamos
es del tate por la propensión marginal
al consumo pero si este es el efecto
sobre la agricultora cuál va a ser el
efecto total en el gasto de esta
economía simplificada básicamente en
esta situación x es igual a esto
quitarle del tate a la granjera es como
decir que x es igual a esto entonces x
es igual a esto pero cuál va a ser el
impacto bueno pues el gasto ahora va a
ser igual a x que es del tate negativo
por la propensión marginal al consumo
esto es igual a esto por el
multiplicador que es 1 sobre uno menos
la propensión marginal al consumo o si
quieren expresar el multiplicador como
el incremento derivado de los impuestos
o multiplicador fiscal sería igual a del
tate por el negativo de la propensión
marginal al consumo sobre uno menos la
propensión marginal al consumo aunque
esta expresión parece muy sofisticada y
técnica lo único que está indicando es
que si le quitamos dinero a la
agricultora este será el efecto sobre su
gasto
y entonces de esa función vamos a
obtener este multiplicador en los
impuestos este negativo es porque si
tenemos un impuesto aquí habrá una
disminución en el gasto por causa del
multiplicador y tal vez hayan visto una
fórmula similar en la que el denominador
tiene un aspecto distinto en ese caso se
trata de algo llamado propensión
marginal al ahorro o pm gs pero que es
supongamos que tenemos una propensión
marginal al consumo de 0.3 esto quiere
decir que vamos a gastar 30 centavos de
cada dólar que obtenemos cuánto vamos a
ahorrar bueno si gastamos 30 centavos
vamos a ahorrar el resto entonces
nuestra propensión marginal al ahorro en
este ejemplo va a ser 70 centavos otra
manera de pensar en esto es nuestra
propensión marginal al consumo más
nuestra propensión marginal al ahorro
debe ser igual a 1 también podemos
restar la propensión marginal al consumo
en ambos lados y la propensión marginal
al ahorro será igual a 1 menos
la propensión marginal al consumo esto
es exactamente igual a esto y es por eso
que a veces
ver una fórmula para el multiplicador
fiscal vamos a escribirlo multiplicador
fiscal es igual a el negativo de la
propensión marginal al consumo sobre en
vez de uno menos la propensión marginal
al consumo la propensión marginal al
ahorro cuando estamos aprendiendo esto
en economía parece muy enigmático de
dónde salió esto que es p mgs que es p
mgc hay que memorizar todas estas cosas
pero como pueden ver todo esto proviene
de un álgebra relativamente sencilla a
veces los economistas tienen una gran
habilidad para hacer que el álgebra
sencilla parezca más complicada de lo
necesario en el siguiente vídeo vamos a
hacer algunos ejemplos prácticos para
aplicar estas fórmulas y ver si tienen
sentido nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo